i don't think it's a secret that we
moved up for him
because of what we thought about him as
a person as a player
we gave him that extension because of
the same things and so
um when you have players like that
they're like fingers on your hands um
you know you can't even imagine that
they're not
part of you that they're not here and
you know that's that's how we feel about
carson
[Music]
the date on that was january 4 and it
was january 4
2021 not 2020 not 2019 not any other
year
but just uh six or so ago oh they
hey thank you thank you john lynch
that and it's nothing personal against
john lynch he's learned the job after
four years
you got to say things in a public
setting that may not mesh with what you
actually
feel because when you are too candid
with what you feel
you end up making it harder to do
business so perfect example
of of why i said that i don't believe
anything that john lynch had to say
about
jimmy garoppolo now that carson wentz is
gone though the job falls to jalen hurts
plus whoever they may bring in to
compete
with jalen hurts and the eagles believe
and and i've been told
that they think backup quarterback is a
top 15 position on the roster peter king
said last week they view it as a top 10
position
i'm going to stick with what i heard as
top 15. either way
you got to go get somebody else whether
it's through the draft they've got the
sixth overall pick
or via free agency or a trade or
something
to go along with jalen hurts compete
with jalen hurts and in theory win the
job
yeah that's absolutely right mike and
you look at maybe a quarterback like
jacoby brissette and you know could he
possibly be a guy that could come in or
do they draft a quarterback adjust the
fields
or a trey lance to come in and compete
so they've got a lot of options here
they don't have a lot of salary cap
space we know but they do have a lot of
options with with what they want to do
with that position but
i do think they need somebody to compete
with hurts i mean we haven't seen enough
of hertz and they haven't seen enough of
hurts mike
to know that he is the guy he is the
future franchise quarterback for this
team i mean you just
i i know they drafted him in second
round but he played
started four games last year so you
haven't seen enough to know exactly what
you have and it might
i'd have to go back and do the research
and really think about it but i can't
think of another super bowl team that
has flat out disintegrated
so quickly that that had its head coach
and its supposed franchise quarterback
and the super bowl mvp backup
quarterback
all of them gone three years later
that's probably unprecedented now it's
it's
somewhat unprecedented that you've got a
franchise quarterback starter
and a backup who's the super bowl mvp
but just the idea that we've seen
so much turnover in such a short period
of time
it almost feels like this team's
resetting at a time when we thought
maybe
they they would have they would have had
another
super bowl trophy i know going into the
2019 season i said if carson wentz stays
healthy wired a wire
they're going to be a team that could go
back and win it again with him as the
quarterback not nick false
yeah and it just didn't happen for him
mike for whatever reason this team did
disintegrate in a hurry
and you look at just how bad i mean we
were still picking them
to win the nfc east that's how bad the
nfc east was
late into the season i mean really late
into the season and they finished with
four wins so
this turned out to be a really bad team
in a really bad
division and they have a long way to go
to get back to where they once were
winning that super bowl mike
yeah we'll see what happens with the
eagles as they begin this process
of putting bodies around coach nick
ciriani and quarterback
jalen hurts starting with the question
of who the other quarterback will be so
let's get to our
our standard formula for every one of
these teams
one player in each one player out each
let's start with who we think is going
to join the eagles
who wasn't on the team last season
sheree
well i'm going to go with jacoby
brucette who i mentioned earlier because
he played for siriani for three years in
indianapolis he can provide
veteran competition i realize you're
saying well jacoby bersett is not great
i get that he didn't have a great season
with indianapolis when he was their
starter they went out and replaced them
with philip rivers but
they don't have the money to go out and
get a really huge name a jameis winston
or somebody else
and do you want to use that draft pick
that top 10 draft pick on a quarterback
maybe you do but i want to see what i
have in jalen hurts i want to let him
compete for that job i did use the
second round pick on him last year
so i want to see what i have in him and
use that pick on another position that's
what i would do at this point
again they're not a team mike i see is
competing for a championship this season
so let's begin that rebuild process and
and see what we have in jail hurts if he
can be our quarterback
i'm fascinated with the possibility of
nick foles coming back for what would be
his third
stint with the eagles drafted in 2012
traded away a few years later back in
2017
obviously super bowl mvp that season
he's not a starter
and he never will be a consistent
successful starter he's the guy who
comes in
when the starter gets injured and it
works it doesn't work when he's the
starter
it does work when he's the backup and
that would be a very valuable backup and
it would mean jalen hurts as the starter
nick foles would be a backup who's
brought in to solely be the backup
brissette maybe would have the door open
to possibly start over jalen hurts if he
could win that competition
and i think we also have to watch a
couple of other former cults ty hilton
marlon mack couple of skill position
guys
who are going to be on the market mac is
a guy they could probably get for cheap
uh coming off of the torn achilles that
he suffered way back i think in week one
of the 2020 season
you plug him into that depth chart if
he's healthy and he makes you better
running the football so uh you know it
makes sense to be looking at
the connective tissue between nick
ceriani and guys
that he already knows who do you think
is going to be off of the roster
beyond carson wentz yeah and we already
know a bunch of moves they're going to
make and have made you know desean
jackson's gone and malik jefferson and
now sean jeffrey are going to be post
june 1 cuts mike but
the guy probably we haven't talked
enough about who i think is going to be
on his way out the door zach ertz i i do
think they they move on from him
you know he had a disastrous season and
it began with he felt betrayed that he
was promised
uh that they would rework his contract
whether that happened or not who knows
but that's the way he felt anyway and
then he goes out and has a really bad
year he plays
11 games 30 catches 335 yards and a
touchdown
statistically was the worst season of
his career they already have dallas
goddard at that position
they need upgrades at receivers to go
with dallas goddard
but i think he's a guy mike that i see
on his way out out of philadelphia
another guy i think to keep an eye on
and it creates some significant cap
space eight figures of it if they
if they cut derrick barnett before his
fifth year option becomes fully
guaranteed on the first day of the
league year
now i think that rule's changing and i
think it kicks in
for the 2018 class 2019 at the latest
that when they exercise the option it is
fully guaranteed not just
injury guaranteed but barnett could be
gone because that's a quick way
to pick up a big big piece of salary
caps basically the thing they could do
is just go to him and say hey we're
gonna cut you
and uh you know here's here's our
alternative offer feel free to shop it
if you want
but this is what we're going to pay you
if you uh if you would
decide to stay but otherwise you're
going to be out of here he's shown
potential at times
but but that 10 million dollar plus
price tag a little bit too much
for the the eagles and i agree with you
as well zach hurts it's just a matter of
time before he's gone and maybe they
don't find a trade partner it may be
that they just have to flat out release
zach hurts he hasn't been happy there
um and it's pretty clear that he's going
to move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports